man i got my brother in here from
another man freddie gears man
the latest signing for uh cte what's up
guests
man you already know out here in vegas
man that's what 115 degrees man
it's hot as hell man so uh why don't
y'all uh you know explain how y'all got
together man
what was that what was the initial
contact man um you know first of all my
man 15 hit me carpet one five and he was
like he's a kid out of gary indiana man
he's dope he got his own movement his
own following yeah and he showed me a
few videos and and i was like damn okay
i get it but you know it wasn't until i
met him when i'm saying i had a chance
to get in the studio kick it with him
you know we definitely had strip clubs a
few times
we did that you know you know i just
kind of realized he was a lot like me
but you know just from a different city
in a different town yeah and like i said
earlier you know we got hoods everywhere
but gary's with no city like you know
the whole city is definitely hood right
right right and you know what i'm saying
he explains that struggle and i just
feel like you know the world needs to
hear that yeah you know i'm saying i
want to be you know a bigger part of
that as i possibly could and here we are
here man we probably about 20 records in
and we grind and man it's the world when
is uh
gibbs when is when is the debut album on
cte coming out man cause i know straight
killer came out last year you just
dropped the joint with static selector
what's next i don't know man i'm just
working man wherever the chips fall i
ain't even tripping on that man i'm just
staying relevant man that's what's up
with me you know what i mean you got
talking to the mic sonic stand in these
people's faces man i really you know i
ain't got no set date for nothing i'm
just on the grind man so right now
there's no way i'm just making sure you
make sure i'm in your face that day
that's all you're one of those artists
that like
you like like you you roll with young
jesus you're street certified but you
could still like do a whole ep with
static selector on the like boom back
hip-hop technique because i know how to
rap man
you know what i'm saying so it's like
you know how to rap it's easy you know i
mean just because you know i mean i'm
from the streets you know i mean i still
can flex on these
dudes walking around with their
backpacks on they think they can rap i
can rap you know better than them so
there it is there it is man so uh the
real is back too yeah yeah you got how
many records together on there a lot
you're all up man it's too hard man yeah
but i'm i'm gonna be clear
it's really back too truck it's gonna be
crazy come on man it's over with it
ain't no turning back what can you tell
us about the uh record together y'all
did together for the album
um it's so many like what we're gonna
probably end up doing is just picking
the best one okay and i'm saying what we
don't put on on the mixtape you know i
mean we probably keep actually um we
just dropped i don't think uh gibbs even
though yeah we just dropped uh do it for
you video so if y'all want to check it
out
yo uh before y'all go last night
cat williams was at the phoenix show
it's only a world star that he was
fighting somebody or got beat up by
slick or something
first of all we don't we don't jump over
what i don't tolerate is when you come
to my job and
make my job so it was for whoever was
concerned i don't give a damn
what i'm saying don't come while i'm
doing what i'm doing and you know and
and and no cause confusion right so
that's what it was about
but it definitely didn't have nothing to
do with us but at the same time you
don't come to no chisel show and fight
cause if you do you better go outside
and catch you with fade and whoever wins
y'all come back in we're gonna continue
the show let that be some advice for
tonight everybody love you everybody
love everybody
the cat was on one man he was happy he's
always old school
and he's in vegas right now hopefully
you don't care what up cat i'll explore
bootleg